هاي اسمك ايه
مروه وانت انا جوليا عندك كم سنه يا مروه
18 انت شكلك برضو لا انا 22 يا لهوي عليك
خالص ما انا شكلي صغير شويه
عارفين ايه اكتر حاجه بتتطلب مننا في
حياتنا انتروديو
ومش طول الوقت السؤال ده بيجي اند فورم
اوف ذا
بتاع بليز
هو موجود حوالينا طول الوقت يعني مثلا
دخلت كومينتي جديده قابلت حد زي مروه
اللي بيحصل في دماغنا ان احنا بنروح
فاتحين دفتر كاتبين مروه 18 سنه في مدرسه
كذا كذا
وزي ما مروه بقت كده في دماغي انا كمان
بقيت في دماغ مروه جوليا 22 سنه بتدرس
بس هل انا كده فعلا عرفت مروه هل انا عرفت
هي مين هل انا عرفت ايه اللي بيفرقها عن
منى اللي هي صاحبتها برضو في المدرسه
وعندها 18 سنه وشبهها حتى شعرها
ايه اللي بيخلي مروه فريده من نوعها يونيك
احنا هناخذ مخك بكل افكارك بكل
نحطه في جسم منى وهناخد مخ منى بافكارها
نحطه في جسم مروه وهندي مروه اختيار ان هي
حد منهم هتديه مليون دولار والتاني هتموته
مروه بتتحط في موقف ان هي محتاجه تختار يا
اما بين جسمها اللي فيه شخصيه منى فهي هنا
هتتخلى عن شخصيتها وافكارها او جسم منى
اللي فيه شخصيتها هي
لما سالوا ناس كتير بالاكس دي معظم الناس
فده ابتدى
[موسيقى]
يدينال اي اونتي بتلايفين
لحد ما بعد شويه جه حد اسمه
اللي انتم بتحاولوا ان هي
على قد ما دي حاجه لبريتن جدا ان انا مش
لازم افضل نفس الشخص ومش لازم افضل باستيك
نفس الحاجه طول الوقت على قد ما هي حاجه
قله البيض انثى لينك ما انا في الاول وفي
الاخر لازم يبقى عندي نقطه ثابته وارجعلها
في حياتي يعني انا لو تهت ابص فين
كتبت كتاب اسمه finding
اشمعنا نويل ستوري عشان دي النجمه الوحيده
اللي مكانها ثابت في السماء
في بتتكلم ان كل حد فينا عنده نوع عنده
حاجه ثابته في حياته وجوانا اثنين الانسان
دي اللي هو انا دي اللي انا مولود بها من
ساعه ما اتولدت عادي واللي بتفضل عارفه
طريق النوع بتاعي
هي السلف اللي انا
بتخليني اعرف اتعامل مع الناس اللي حواليا
بتخليني عندي
والكي ان انا اوصل للنوع بتاعي ان الاتنين
يبقوا
كتير قوي اللي بيحصل ان احنا
في الاخر دي اللي بتخلي بابا وماما
مبسوطين وتخلي عندي صحاب وبتخليني روش
وعلى قد ما انا نفسي ان كلنا نخلي بابا
مبسوطين يبقى عندنا اصحاب ونبقى روشين
ساعات كتير قوي لما بقفل الموضوع بيجي
باضرار صغير زي مثلا هحكي لكم على اشرف
اخو منى اشرف بيلعب تنس
طول حياته رايح فين رايح تمرين التنس راجع
منين راجع من التمرين التنس او نازل يجيب
جزمه تنس او مضرب تانس او بيتضرب فتنس
عشان التنس
اللي اشرف مش عارفه ان احنا هننفع شهرين
في حياته هنكتشف ان اشرف وهو بيلعب تنس
هيتزحلق وهيقع على كتفه واحتمال ايده
تتكسر
ساعتها اصرف هيبقى مين لو هو مش اسره في
تونس هيبقى مين
كثير قوي قوي بنحط ايدينتيتي كلها في حته
معينه بتاعه
وممكن انا كمان ابقى مبسوط بها عادي بس
ما ينفعش احط على نفسي ليبل كبير قوي وقرر
ان انا كل هويتي هتدور حوالين دي هقول لكم
حاجه حصلت معايا حد هنا اي دي مين هنا اي
دي اوكي
[موسيقى]
بيعمل حاجه قوي بس هو كان في جمل كتير قوي
بتتقال
بتخلي الموضوع صعب صعب
والموضوع فضل يتقال لي دحاها دحيحه دحاحه
لحد ما جيت في امتحان
سبت سؤال مش عشان انا ما كنتش عارفاه انا
كنت عارفاه كويس قوي بس انا ما كنتش قادره
اطلع من الامتحان واسمع انت جبت 102 تاني
ولا ايه
ما كنتش قادره
فكتير قوي قوي لما بافاليو كلام الناس
اللي حواليا اكتر من نفسي
ببتدي اسيب حاجات بس عشان هي مش عاجبه
الناس اللي حواليا مع ان انا كنت مبسوطه
بس انا كنت بسيب السؤال ده علشان بس ما
يتقاليش انها دحيحه
الفكره انه
موضوع ان انا اسيب سؤال في امتحان ايفلت
فيري هذه طول الامتحان ما كنتش قادره قفلت
كنت حاسه اني مقيده جدا
اللي اكتشفته بعد كده ان دي كانت طريقه
بتقول لي بيها انه
دي مش حاجه لذيذه قوي لك فقعدت اقرا
اكتشفت انه
عندها طرق ان هي تقول لنا يس
الحاجه دي حلوه وينو الحاجه دي مش حلوه
نقول الحاجه دي مش حلوه مش معناها ان هي
مش حلوه على بعضها معناها ان هي
زي مثلا
الاوقات اللي بيقع عندنا فيها كثير
بنضحك بصوت عالي والاوقات اللي احنا بجد
بنحس ان احنا خلاص مش قادر عايزه اروح
اقعد في البيت
اولي في نوع انفرميشن انا بفتكره من غير
ما احط قفله اصلا وفي نوع ثاني بقعد احاول
احفظه وما بيتحفظش ميبي دوتنج وده لا
او مثلا مثلا
الاوقات اللي بيبقى عندي فيها
كويسه ببقى هل فيه ماي بادي بيبقى اكتف
والاوقات اللي ببقى عيان فيها كل مره زي
مثلا قبل الامتحانات ده بيبقى
او حاجه كلنا بنعدي بها بس ممكن ما نبقاش
كلنا بنفكر فيها الوقت بيعدي هنا بسرعه
قوي قوي ما بنحسش به بنلاقي خمس ساعات
عدوا كده اهو او في مواقف تاني الوقت
بيعدي بالراحه جدا لدرجه ان احنا بنبقى
هنموت من الزهق خلاص دي بتبقى حاجه
ودي حاجه
بنبتدي نعرف او دايركشن بنبتدي نعرف
لايف
سلوني
ولما بنبتدي نركز فيهم اكتر بنبتدي نضيف
انتم
بنبتدي نتعرف على نفسنا اكثر بنبتدي ما
نبقاش بس سننا والميجر بتاعنا
والتمرين مثلا
زي مروه مروه ما طلعتش بس كده هي طلعت حد
بجد بيهتم قوي بالناس اللي حواليه بيهتم
ان هم كلهم يبقوا مبسوطين
في الاخر احب اقول لكم هاي انا جوليا اند
اي لوف ذايند
[تصفيق]